Pino Audia teaches in the business school at Dartmouth, and he researches, among other things, the question: How do entrepreneurs get created? And somebody noticed that his students and many of his colleagues actually have an opinion about this. They believe entrepreneurs make themselves. You know, you bravely head off on your own. You write a business plan. You start in your own garage. And that garage, by the way, is not a metaphor. Hewlett-Packard started in a garage. Apple Computer had a garage. Disney, the Mattel Toy Company, the Wham-O Toy Company.
皮诺·奥迪亚在达特茅斯商学院任教，他研究的课题之一是：创业者是如何产生的？有人注意到他的学生和许多同事对此确实有看法。他们相信创业者是靠自己造就的。你知道，你勇敢地踏上自己的道路，写一份商业计划，从自家车库开始。顺便说一句，那个车库并不是隐喻。惠普公司始于一个车库。苹果电脑也有一个车库。迪士尼、美泰玩具公司、Wham-O玩具公司都是如此。
It is about big dreams and humble beginnings and success in the face of adversity and doubters, and also the idea that regardless of who you are, regardless of how humble your beginnings are, you can turn something into an immense success story if you work hard. And that was the point in time at which I got interested in the story of the garage as a myth.
这是关于远大的梦想、卑微的起点、面对逆境和怀疑者的成功，以及这样一种观念：无论你是谁，无论你的出身多么卑微，只要你努力工作，就能将某样事物变成一个巨大的成功故事。就在那个时候，我对车库作为一种神话的故事产生了兴趣。
A garage is a place of possibilities. It's a place where things can get invented and a place where entrepreneurs begin.
车库是充满可能性的地方。它是一个可以发明事物的地方，也是创业者起步的地方。
This is from a promotional video that Hewlett-Packard put together after it spent millions to buy and restore the original garage where its two founders started what is now the largest technology firm in the world.
这段话来自惠普公司制作的一段宣传视频，此前他们花费数百万美元购买并修复了最初的那个车库，两位创始人正是在那里创办了现在全球最大的科技公司。
In 1938, in a garage in Palo Alto, California, Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard set to work to start a new company. They had a few hand-operated punches, a used Sears Roebuck drill press that had just made the trip west in the back of one of their cars, and they had a rented flat with a garage.
1938年，在加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托的一个车库里，比尔·休利特和戴夫·帕卡德开始着手创办一家新公司。他们有几台手动冲床，一台二手的西尔斯·罗巴克钻床——那台钻床刚被装在他们其中一辆车的后备箱里从西边运过来——他们还租了一间带车库的公寓。
Professor Audia doesn't argue with any of this. But he says that when you ask actual entrepreneurs, and this is true in survey after survey, you find that most of them began not by going off into their garage, but by working for somebody else, making contacts, learning the business.
奥迪亚教授并不反驳这些说法。但他表示，当你询问真正的创业者时，而且在一次又一次的调查中都是如此，你会发现他们中的大多数人起步时并不是走进车库，而是通过为别人工作、建立人脉、学习行业知识来开始的。
So this is a very robust finding, which tells us that actually if you want to become an entrepreneur, the obvious thing to do is to first go get a job in an industry you're interested in and learn, and then eventually, later try to create a company.
所以这是一个非常扎实的发现，它告诉我们，如果你真的想成为一名创业者，显而易见的事情是先在你感兴趣的行业找一份工作并学习，然后最终在未来尝试创办一家公司。
Even Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard weren't exactly outsiders. They studied electrical engineering at MIT and at Stanford. Packard had worked at General Electric. A former professor of theirs from Stanford gave them leads and hooked them up, for example, with a firm called Litton Engineering. He let them use equipment that they didn't own themselves yet. Just as, decades later, the founders of Apple Computer, 21-year-old Steve Jobs, was already working at Atari, and 25-year-old old Steve Wozniak was at Hewlett-Packard when they started Apple in Job's garage.
即使是比尔·休利特和戴夫·帕卡德也不完全是局外人。他们在麻省理工学院和斯坦福大学学习电气工程。帕卡德曾在通用电气工作。他们的一位斯坦福大学前教授为他们提供了线索，例如，将他们与一家名为利顿工程的公司联系起来。他让他们使用他们自己还未拥有的设备。就像几十年后，苹果电脑的创始人，21岁的史蒂夫·乔布斯当时已经在雅达利工作，而25岁的史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克在苹果公司在乔布斯的车库开办时，正效力于惠普。
And, for example, in the case of Steve Jobs, he benefited greatly from the support that he got from the Atari people, because they introduced him to investors.
而且，以史蒂夫·乔布斯为例，他从雅达利员工那里得到的支持中受益匪浅，因为他们将他介绍给了投资者。
Pino Audia has tried to find mentions of garage entrepreneurs or anything like it in other countries and didn't come up with much. He says it seems to be a very American idea, very close to other American ideas about opportunity for everybody. The Apple and Hewlett-Packard garages have now become such a part of Silicon Valley myth that it's made other tech companies want their own stories like it.
皮诺·奥迪亚试图在其他国家寻找有关车库创业者或类似事物的提及，但没有发现多少。他说这似乎是一个非常美国的想法，非常接近其他关于人人都有机会的美国理念。苹果和惠普的车库现在已经成为硅谷神话的一部分，这使得其他科技公司也想要拥有属于自己的类似故事。
Google, for example. They did not start in a garage. The founders began working on their search engine in 1996 when they were at Stanford. They didn't actually move into a garage until 1998. They already had investors, and they were just in the garage for five months. But in 2006, Google bought the garage as a company landmark.
例如谷歌。他们并不是从车库开始的。创始人在1996年身在斯坦福大学时就开始研究他们的搜索引擎。直到1998年，他们才真正搬进一个车库。当时他们已经有了投资者，并且在车库里只待了五个月。但在2006年，谷歌买下了那个车库作为公司地标。
It's like, no one wants to hear the story of the rich, well-connected guys who meet up at the Marriott conference room to hatch a business plan. There's no romance in that.
这就好比，没有人想听那些富有、人脉广泛的家伙在万豪酒店会议室碰面制定商业计划的故事。那里面没有任何浪漫色彩。
Dan Heath has written about these origin stories in Fast Company magazine. He says that one way to measure just how appealing these stories are is to count all the ones that get quoted widely, even though they aren't remotely true. For instance, when eBay began, a story circulated that its founder created the company so his fiancee could buy and collect Pez dispensers more easily. Not true. One of the creators of YouTube used to claim that the idea for the business came after a dinner party in 2005, where two of the company's masterminds, Chad Hurley and Steve Chen, shot some video and then tried to post it online and found out just how hard that was back then.
丹·希思在《快公司》杂志上写过这些起源故事。他说，衡量这些故事有多么吸引人的一种方法是统计那些被广泛引用的故事，尽管它们根本不是真的。例如，eBay刚开始时，曾流传一个故事，说其创始人创建该公司是为了让他的未婚妻能更轻松地购买和收藏贝兹糖果机。这不是真的。YouTube的创作者之一曾经声称，这个商业点子是在2005年的一次晚宴后产生的，当时该公司的两位主谋查德·赫利和史蒂夫·陈拍摄了一些视频，然后试图将其发布到网上，却发现当时这有多么困难。
Now, that is, at a minimum, an exaggerated tale. In fact, there's a third founder of YouTube who claims the dinner party never happened. And Steve Chen later admitted in TIME Magazine that the dinner party was embellished to provide a better founding myth.
现在，这至少是一个夸大的故事。事实上，还有第三位YouTube创始人声称晚宴从未发生过。史蒂夫·陈后来在《时代》周刊上承认，晚宴的情节是为了提供一个更好的创业神话而润色的。
And I do want to say that while it feels like a little bit of a letdown to realize that this dinner party story is not the whole truth, I feel like it's a little bit unfair for us to expect more of them than the creation of YouTube. I mean, here's this incredible site, and in some sense, that's not enough for us. We want YouTube to have emerged from some kind of everyday experience. It's like it's not enough to have the value of their work. We also want there to be a really compelling story that started it.
我想说的是，虽然意识到晚宴的故事并非全部事实让人感到有点失望，但我认为我们对他们的期望超过了创建YouTube本身，这有点不公平。我的意思是，这是一个了不起的网站，在某种意义上，这已经足够了。我们希望YouTube从某种日常经历中产生。这就好像仅仅拥有他们工作的价值还不够。我们还希望有一个真正引人入胜的故事作为起点。
Now, in the article that you wrote for Fast Company, you point out that our attachment to these kinds of mythic creation stories is so strong that we have even exaggerated the Christopher Columbus story.
在你为《快公司》撰写的文章中，你指出我们对这些神话般的创作故事的依恋非常强烈，以至于我们甚至夸大了克里斯托弗·哥伦布的故事。
Well, Christopher Columbus, as we all know, wanted to prove that he could reach India by sailing west. But no one believed his crazy theory that the Earth was round. And, in fact, his own sailors en route were terrified that they were about to fall over the edge of the Earth, and they almost mutinied.
众所周知，克里斯托弗·哥伦布想证明他可以通过向西航行到达印度。但没有人相信他关于地球是圆的疯狂理论。事实上，他自己的船员在航行途中害怕得以为他们即将从地球边缘坠落，甚至差点哗变。
So there's a guy named James Loewen, a professor at University of Vermont, who has pointed out that virtually every element of this story is false. That, in fact, we still don't really know where Christopher Columbus was going. There's a lot of disagreement among historians that even Columbus' best-known biographer isn't totally sure where he was headed. And furthermore, there was no element of is the Earth round or flat here. Most people at that time already knew that the Earth was round. The evidence was there for them to see. They noticed that, if another ship is receding into the horizon, their hull disappears first, and then the mast later, which implies that there's some kind of curvature in play.
因此，佛蒙特大学的一位名叫詹姆斯·洛温的教授指出，这个故事中几乎每一个要素都是错误的。事实上，我们至今仍不确定克里斯托弗·哥伦布要去哪里。历史学家之间存在很多分歧，即使是哥伦布最著名的传记作者也不完全确定他的目的地。此外，这里根本不存在地球是圆的还是平的问题。当时大多数人已经知道地球是圆的。证据就在他们眼前。他们注意到，如果另一艘船向地平线驶去，船体先消失，然后是桅杆，这意味着存在某种曲率。
And again, here's a guy who crossed an ocean and became one of the first Europeans to set foot on a new continent, and yet, we want more from this guy. We want him to be having hand-to-hand combat with his crew en route. We just crave the drama. We crave the obstacles.
再一次，这是一个横渡大洋并成为第一批踏上新大陆的欧洲人之一的家伙，然而，我们对他有更高的要求。我们希望他在航行途中与船员进行肉搏战。我们只是渴望戏剧性，渴望障碍。
For today on our show: origin stories. We love them so much that sometimes it is hard not to make them up. And so today on our show, we bring you three origin stories, true ones. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天的节目主题是：起源故事。我们太爱它们了，以至于有时很难不去编造它们。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们要带给你三个起源故事，真实的那些。来自芝加哥WBEZ，《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our show today: Mad Man. Act Two: The Secret Life of Secrets. Act Three: Wait Wait-- Don't Film Me. Act Four: Bill Clinton's 7-Year-Old Brother. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的第一幕：广告狂人。第二幕：秘密的秘密生活。第三幕：等等等等——别拍我。第四幕：比尔·克林顿的7岁弟弟。请继续收听。
Act  One. Well, this first story is about a fight over the origin of certain ideas, a fight over who really came up with those ideas. Sarah Koenig tells a story about her dad Julian.
第一幕。好吧，这个第一个故事是关于一场关于某些想法起源的争论，一场关于究竟是谁真正想出这些想法的斗争。莎拉·科尼格讲述了她父亲朱利安的故事。
All my life, I've heard the hallmarks of my father's achievements.
我一生都在听父亲成就的标志。
I invented thumb wrestling.
我发明了拇指摔跤。
That was in 1936 when he was a counselor at Camp Greylock for boys. They already had arm wrestling for the boys and leg wrestling.
那是在1936年，他在格雷洛克夏令营当辅导员的时候。男孩子们已经有了臂力摔跤和腿部摔跤。
But we needed another wrestling, and I invented thumb wrestling with the same rules as a hockey puck face-off. One, two, three, go!
但我需要另一种摔跤，我发明了拇指摔跤，规则和冰球争球一样。一、二、三，开始！
It just came to you, like just a stroke? Oh, we should use our thumbs?
它就这么出现在你脑海里，就像灵光一现？哦，我们应该用我们的拇指？
Yeah, it was just a devastating moment.
是的，那是一个决定性的时刻。
The discoveries kept coming. Shrimp, for instance.
发现还在继续。例如，虾。
I wanted to popularize shrimp in America.
我想在美国普及虾。
In 1941, my father, a shrimp lover, was discouraged that there were only two places on Broadway in New York where you could get shrimp. So then in Biloxi, Mississippi-- and bear with me here, because this story barely makes any sense. So he's in Biloxi, on his way to Mexico with some buddies, and he sees this government boat about to go out to track the migratory path of shrimp. And he talks his way onto the boat by explaining that he loves shrimp apparently, and he goes out on this boat, and they find the shrimp breeding grounds or some such. The rest, of course, is history.
1941年，我的父亲，一位虾爱好者，对纽约百老汇只有两家能吃到虾的地方感到沮丧。后来在密西西比州比洛克西——请耐心听我说，因为这个故事几乎毫无逻辑。他在去墨西哥的路上，和几个朋友在一起，看到了这艘政府调查船正要出发去追踪虾的迁徙路径。他向他们解释说他很喜欢虾，居然就成功混上了船，他们发现了虾的繁殖地之类的。当然，剩下的就是历史了。
Then back in New York, I patrolled Broadway and [UNINTELLIGIBLE], asking for shrimp, shrimp, shrimp! More! And in this way, talking it up, I popularized shrimp. No question about it.
然后回到纽约，我巡视百老汇，询问虾、虾、虾！更多！通过这种方式，谈论它，我普及了虾。毫无疑问。
That seems like really, really thin evidence that you popularized shrimp in New York.
这似乎是非常、非常薄弱的证据，证明你在纽约普及了虾。
Well, I'm not making any claim on the industry.
好吧，我并没有对整个行业提出任何要求。
My dad does make a claim on the word "character," that he came up with the idea to use it to mean a person of unusual or eccentric qualities.
我父亲确实对“角色”（character）这个词提出了主张，说他想出了用这个词来指代一个具有不同寻常或古怪特质的人的想法。
You have a character in a play, of course, but it wasn't in common usage as he's a character.
戏剧里当然有角色，但“他是个角色”这种说法并不是常用用法。
And what made you-- do you remember why you started using it?
是什么让你——你还记得你为什么开始这样用吗？
I just shifted it, adopted it. Though Norman Mailer thinks that he developed it, I take precedence.
我只是转换了它，采用了它。虽然诺曼·梅勒认为是他开发的，但我享有优先权。
According to my father, Norman Mailer also said he invented thumb wrestling. Mailer, who died in 2007, was a famous thumb wrestler, but not its inventor. Because as we now know, my dad invented it at Camp Greylock for boys. And that's the rub. You can't prove the origin of any of this stuff, and it's annoying when people like Norman Mailer take credit.
根据我父亲的说法，诺曼·梅勒也曾说他发明了拇指摔跤。梅勒于2007年去世，是一位著名的拇指摔跤手，但不是发明者。因为正如我们现在所知，我父亲在格雷洛克男童夏令营发明了它。这就是症结所在。你无法证明任何这些东西的起源，当像诺曼·梅勒这样的人抢功时，这很烦人。
My dad would like people to recognize him for his contributions to shrimp and character and thumb wrestling. But he's not going to make a stink if they don't. His real legacy, though, in advertising, that's another story. That, he's willing to fight for, and he has been fighting for it for decades.
我父亲希望人们认可他在虾、角色和拇指摔跤方面的贡献。但如果他们不认可，他也不会大闹。然而，他在广告界的真正遗产是另一回事。那是他愿意为之奋斗的东西，而且他已经为之奋斗了几十年。
My father was a legendary copywriter. He wrote "Timex Takes a Licking and Keeps on Ticking." He named Earth Day "Earth Day." It falls on his birthday, April 22. Earth Day, birthday. So the idea came easily. The magazine Advertising Age made a list of the top 100 advertising campaigns of the 20th century. The Marlboro Man is on it and the Energizer Bunny, "Good to the Last Drop" from Maxwell House and the "Keep America Beautiful" crying Indian.
我父亲是一位传奇的文案撰稿人。他写了“天美时（Timex）经得起考验，依然精准走时”。他将地球日命名为“地球日”。它正好在他生日那天，4月22日。地球日，生日。所以这个点子想出来很容易。《广告时代》杂志列出了20世纪100大广告活动。万宝路男人在名单上，还有劲量兔子，麦斯威尔咖啡的“滴滴香浓，意犹未尽”，以及“保持美国美丽”的流泪印第安人广告。
But the number-one ad, the top of the 100 list? "Think Small." That was Volkswagen's American campaign to sell the Beetle in 1959, and my father wrote it. A picture of a tiny car on a big, white page and some amused self-deprecating copy. That ad was followed by Lemon, another VW ad so iconic it made it onto the TV show Mad Men , the show set in 1960 about an ad agency that's slightly behind the times. In this scene, the agency's creative team contemplates the Lemon ad.
但是排名第一的广告，100大名单的榜首呢？“想想小（Think Small）”。那是大众汽车1959年在美国销售甲壳虫汽车的广告活动，我父亲写的。一张大白纸上的一辆微型汽车，还有一些自嘲式的文案。那则广告之后是“柠檬（Lemon）”，另一则大众广告，非常经典，甚至出现在了电视剧《广告狂人》中，该剧设定在1960年，讲述了一家稍微落后于时代的广告代理公司。在这一幕中，代理公司的创意团队正在审视那则柠檬广告。
I don't know what I hate about it the most, the ad or the car.
我不知道我最讨厌它什么，是广告还是车。
You know, they did one last year, same kind of smirk. Remember "Think Small?" It was a half-page ad at a full-page buy. You could barely see the product.
你知道，他们去年做过一个，同样的假笑。还记得“想想小”吗？那是半版的广告买的全版的位子。你几乎看不到产品。
I don't get it.
我不明白。
At the time, these ads were revolutionary. "In the beginning, there was Volkswagen," another famous New York ad man wrote. "That was the day when the new advertising agency was really born."
在当时，这些广告是革命性的。“起初，有了大众汽车，”另一位著名的纽约广告人写道。“那一天，新的广告代理公司才真正诞生。”
Here's another scene from Mad Men when Don Draper, the agency's creative director, interviews some new talent. After he looks at their portfolio, he hands it back to them with this line.
这是《广告狂人》中的另一幕，当唐·德雷珀，该公司的创意总监，面试一些新人才时。在看了他们的作品集后，他用这句台词把它还给了他们。
It's Julian Koenig [PRONOUNCES KOENIG AS KAY-NIG] actually. My father. And what has irritated him for so long is not that he's not recognized for his talent. I mean, the people who write Mad Men clearly know who he is. It's that some of his best work has been claimed by someone else.
其实是朱利安·科尼格（发音为KAY-NIG）。我父亲。让他困扰了这么久的不在于他没有因为才华而得到认可。我的意思是，拍《广告狂人》的人显然知道他是谁。而是他的一些最好的作品被别人认领了。
In my instance, the greatest predator of my work was my one-time partner George Lois, who is a most heralded and talented art director/designer, and his talent is only exceeded by his omnivorous ego. So where it once would've been accepted that the word would be "we" did it, regardless of who originated the work, the word "we" evaporated from George's vocabulary and it became "my."
在我的例子中，掠夺我作品的最大掠食者是我曾经的合伙人乔治·洛伊斯，他是一位最受赞誉和有才华的艺术总监/设计师，他的才华只有他那贪婪的自我才能超越。所以，当原本应该被接受的词是“我们”一起完成了它，无论谁原创了作品时，词汇“我们”从乔治的字典里蒸发了，变成了“我的”。
If you've heard of anyone in the advertising industry, it might be George Lois. He's well known for a lot of things, but maybe especially for his provocative and funny Esquire magazine covers from the 1960s, like the one of Muhammad Ali posing as Saint Sebastian. But before that, George Lois worked at Doyle Dane Bernbach, and so did my father. In 1960, they both left DDB and joined up with another guy, Fred Papert, to form their own upstart agency called PKL: Papert, Koenig and Lois.
如果你听说过广告业的任何名字，那可能是乔治·洛伊斯。他因很多事情而闻名，但也许特别是因他20世纪60年代那些挑衅且有趣的《时尚先生》杂志封面，比如穆罕默德·阿里模仿圣塞巴斯蒂安的那一期。但在那之前，乔治·洛伊斯在Doyle Dane Bernbach（DDB）工作，我父亲也在那里。1960年，他们俩都离开了DDB，并与另一个人弗雷德·帕佩特联手，组建了他们自己的创业代理公司PKL：Papert, Koenig and Lois。
George Lois wouldn't talk to me for this story. "I'm not going to get into a sophomoric [BLEEP] fight with a disgruntled ex-partner," he wrote in an email. I can't say I blame him. I've had mixed feelings about this fight. Of course I want to stick up for my father, take his side. But I've also thought there's something inherently undignified about the whole thing, like it's beneath my father to care whether or not George Lois is taking credit for this or that slogan from 1962, so I never really paid attention to the details. Until now. Lately, it's been coming up more, or at least more publicly, so I started asking questions.
乔治·洛伊斯不愿接受我的采访。“我不会和一个不满的前合伙人陷入幼稚的争吵，”他在一封邮件中写道。我不能说我怪他。我对这场争吵的感受很复杂。当然，我想为我父亲辩护，站在他这边。但我也一直认为整件事本质上是失礼的，就像关心乔治·洛伊斯是否在为1962年的这个或那个标语抢功对于我父亲来说太掉价一样，所以我从未真正注意过细节。直到现在。最近，这事被提起的次数更多了，或者至少更公开了，所以我开始提问。
According to my father, it all started with the Harvey Probber account. Harvey Probber made elegant modern furniture, and my dad says he came up with the ad, a beautiful chair with a matchbook under one leg, and the line: "If your Harvey Probber chair wobbles, straighten your floor," and a piece of copy that went with it that he thought was very good.
根据我父亲的说法，这一切始于哈维·普罗伯（Harvey Probber）的客户。哈维·普罗伯制作优雅的现代家具，我父亲说他想出了那则广告，一把漂亮的椅子，一条腿下放着一盒火柴，台词是：“如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子摇晃，那是你的地板不平，”还有一段他认为写得非常好的文案。
And a year or so later or a couple of years later, Ron Holland, a friend of mine, came running into my office to say, George is upstairs with a Japanese editorial writer. They're doing an interview with him, and he's claiming your Harvey Probber chair ad, that he wrote it.
一年左右或几年后，罗恩·霍兰德，我的一个朋友，冲进我的办公室说，乔治在楼上和一个日本编辑作家在一起。他们正在采访他，他在声称你的哈维·普罗伯椅子广告是他写的。
So I called George down to my office and remonstrated-- that's what men do frequently-- with him. And he says, I never said that. I would never say that. And he went back to his office. And a little while later, Ron comes bursting into my office, saying, George said I told that son-of-a-gun where to get off.
所以我把乔治叫到我的办公室，对他进行了严正抗议——男人们经常这样做。他说，我从没那样说。我绝不会那样说。他回到他的办公室。不久之后，罗恩冲进我的办公室说，乔治说我告诉那个混蛋去一边待着。
Meaning you. Meaning he had told you?
指的是你吗？指的是他告诉过你？
Yeah, told me where to get off. So that was really the start of it.
是的，告诉他去一边待着。所以那真的就是开始。
In 1972, George Lois published a book, the first of many, about his career called George, Be Careful. In it, he describes going to the Harvey Probber furniture factory in Massachusetts with my dad.
1972年，乔治·洛伊斯出版了一本书，是他众多书籍中的第一本，关于他的职业生涯，名为《乔治，小心点》。在书中，他描述了和我父亲一起去马萨诸塞州的哈维·普罗伯家具工厂。
"Each chair was placed on an electronic test platform to be sure it was absolutely level," Lois wrote. "'Got a book of matches?' I asked Julian, a heavy smoker. He handed me a matchbook, and I slid it under one leg of the chair on the test platform. 'I've got the ad,' I said. 'If your Harvey Probber chair is crooked, straighten your floor.' Julian scowled and shot back: 'Ass [BLEEP]! If your Harvey Probber chair wobbles, straighten your floor.' That was the way the ad ran, and that was the way we built the first red-hot creative agency."
“每把椅子都被放在一个电子测试平台上，以确保它绝对水平，”洛伊斯写道。“‘有火柴吗？’我问朱利安，他是个大烟民。他递给我一盒火柴，我把它滑到测试平台上椅子的一条腿下。‘我拿到广告了，’我说。‘如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子歪了，拉直你的地板。’朱利安皱着眉头反击道：‘混蛋！如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子摇晃，拉直你的地板。’广告就是那样运行的，我们就是那样建立起第一家红极一时的创意代理公司的。”
And none of that ever happened, as described by George. He didn't ask me for a matchbook. He didn't slide it under the leg of a chair and say, I've got the ad. None of it is true.
这些事从来没发生过，不像乔治描述的那样。他没向我要过火柴盒。他没把它滑到椅腿下并说，我拿到广告了。这一切都不是真的。
But his makes a better story.
但他的版本讲出了更好的故事。
His is a marvelous story. George is a talented storyteller with a vivid imagination. The only thing that could exceed it would be the truth.
他的故事很精彩。乔治是一位有才华的讲故事的人，拥有生动的想象力。唯一能超过它的只有真相。
There were other instances also regarding ads that were groundbreaking for their time. A campaign for the New York Herald Tribune: "Who says a good newspaper has to be dull?" Some famous Xerox commercials showing a little girl operating a copy machine, and later, a chimpanzee doing it, ads several people who worked on the account have complained that George literally had nothing to do with.
还有其他关于在当时具有突破性的广告的例子。为《纽约先驱论坛报》做的广告活动：“谁说好报纸必须沉闷？”一些著名的施乐公司广告，显示一个小女孩操作复印机，后来还有一只黑猩猩在操作，参与该客户工作的几个人抱怨乔治根本没有参与。
Then there's the ad for Coldene cough medicine. The page is entirely black with just two quotes at different heights meant to show a couple talking in bed. "John, is that Billy coughing?" says the wife. "Get up and give him some Coldene," the husband replies.
还有那则Coldene止咳药的广告。整页都是黑的，只有两行不同高度的引语，意指一对夫妇在床上交谈。“约翰，是比利在咳嗽吗？”妻子说。“起来给他吃点Coldene，”丈夫回答。
In an interview 20 years later, George Lois said, "The idea for the ad hit me like a brainstorm. This was the first time there would be no copy, no package design, no trademark," he said. "It was really the beginning of a new creative revolution. It was one of those ads that made history, effectively." Again, my dad is adamant that the whole ad, copy and design were his.
20年后的一次采访中，乔治·洛伊斯说：“这则广告的灵感像灵光一闪击中了我。这是第一次没有文案，没有包装设计，没有商标，”他说。“这确实是一场新的创意革命的开始。这是那些创造历史的广告之一。”再一次，我父亲坚持认为整个广告，文案和设计都是他的。
There are many possibilities here of what's going on. George Lois could be lying. Or George Lois could have convinced himself in some way that what he's saying about all this stuff is true. Or my dad could be doing the same thing, remembering stuff that happened when it didn't happen. Or, I suppose, my dad could be lying. I'd worry about those latter options more if my father was the only one disputing George Lois' version of history. But he's not.
关于发生了什么，这里有很多可能性。乔治·洛伊斯可能在撒谎。或者乔治·洛伊斯可能以某种方式说服了自己，他说的所有这些东西都是真的。或者我父亲可能也在做同样的事，记得一些没发生过的事。或者，我想，我父亲可能在撒谎。如果我父亲是唯一一个对乔治·洛伊斯的历史版本有异议的人，我会更担心后一种选择。但他不是。
There's the photographer Carl Fischer, who worked with George Lois for more than 30 years and shot many of the most famous Esquire covers. Carl Fischer says George is taking credit for cover ideas and photographs that were Carl's and talked in detail about certain photo shoots, like about flying to Las Vegas to shoot the boxer Sonny Liston as Santa, and even placing the Santa cap on Liston's head. Or rushing Italian actress Virna Lisi into a photo shoot in New York for this famous cover where she's pretending to shave her face. But Fischer says George wasn't there for either shoot. In fact, the Lisi shoot happened in Rome, and he still has the receipts to prove it.
还有摄影师卡尔·费舍尔，他和乔治·洛伊斯合作了30多年，拍摄了许多最著名的《时尚先生》封面。卡尔·费舍尔说乔治把卡尔的封面点子和照片据为己有，并详细谈论了特定的拍摄，比如飞往拉斯维加斯拍摄拳击手桑尼·利斯顿扮成圣诞老人的照片，甚至亲自把圣诞帽戴在利斯顿头上。或者匆忙将意大利女演员维尔娜·丽丝带到纽约拍摄这个著名的封面，她在封面上假装刮胡子。但费舍尔说乔治并没有参加这两次拍摄。事实上，丽丝的拍摄是在罗马进行的，他至今还保留着证明这一点的收据。
And then there's Shelly Zalaznick, the first editor of New York magazine. George once told a reporter, quote: "My hand on the Bible, I, George Lois, created New York magazine." Mr. Zalaznick says that's simply not true. He himself remembers making the first dummy front page one hot August night in 1963. Not only that, he's never met George Lois.
还有谢利·扎拉兹尼克，《纽约》杂志的第一任编辑。乔治曾经告诉记者，引述：“我对着圣经发誓，我，乔治·洛伊斯，创建了《纽约》杂志。”扎拉兹尼克先生说那根本不是真的。他本人记得1963年8月一个炎热的夜晚制作第一份样刊封面的情景。不仅如此，他从来没见过乔治·洛伊斯。
As for George's version, he told me, I'm a loss. I don't know why grownups do things like this.
至于乔治的版本，他告诉我，我真是输了。我不知道成年人为什么要做这样的事。
But the story my father objects to the most isn't about ad copy at all. It's personal. Papert, Koenig and Lois had gotten the Dutch Masters cigar account, and their TV spokesman at the time was this famous comedian Ernie Kovacs. So my dad flew out to LA to meet him, and they hit it off.
但我父亲最反对的故事根本不是关于广告文案的。那是私人的。Papert, Koenig and Lois 拿下了荷兰大师雪茄的客户，他们当时的电视代言人是著名的喜剧演员厄尼·科瓦克斯。所以我父亲飞到洛杉矶去见他，他们一拍即合。
And Ernie and I spent the day together, driving around and lunched together, ended the afternoon in the lobby of the hotel I was staying in at the Beverly Hilton. He was not allowed past the lobby because he had short pants on. And then he went off to go to a party that night. And on his way home, it began to rain. His car skidded and went into a pole, and Ernie killed himself. I was on a plane back to New York and learned about it the next morning. So, unfortunate incident, but certainly memorable to me. And lo and behold--
厄尼和我待了一整天，开车到处转，一起吃了午饭，下午在比佛利希尔顿酒店我住的大堂结束。他不被允许进入大堂，因为他穿着短裤。然后他那天晚上去参加一个派对。在回家的路上，开始下雨。他的车打滑撞上了一根电线杆，厄尼自杀了。我在飞回纽约的飞机上，第二天早上得知了这件事。所以，不幸的事件，但对我来说当然难忘。没想到——
Lo and behold, in his 2005 book $elebrities, which is spelled with a dollar sign instead of a "C" at the beginning, George tells the story of his lovely lunch with Ernie, his car ride to the airport with Ernie, his red-eye flight back to New York, and his learning the following morning from a stack of still-bound newspapers that Ernie had been killed in a car crash.
没想到，在他2005年的书《$elebrities》中，乔治讲述了他与厄尼愉快午餐、搭车去机场、红眼航班飞回纽约，以及第二天早上从一叠尚未装订的报纸中得知厄尼在车祸中丧生的故事。
My father has tried to fight back, aggressively at times. For instance, after the Ernie Kovacs story appeared in $elebrities, my dad retaliated in the medium he knows best. He wrote an ad.
我父亲试图反击，有时还很激进。例如，在厄尼·科瓦克斯的故事出现在《$elebrities》之后，我父亲用他最擅长的媒介进行了报复。他写了一则广告。
I wrote an ad: "Low, Lower, Lois."
我写了一则广告：“卑劣，更卑劣，洛伊斯。”
That's Lois, L-O-I-S.
那是洛伊斯（Lois），L-O-I-S。
And I wanted to print it in the New York Times and say: "A book review. A public service book review."
我想把它印在《纽约时报》上，说：“一本书评。一份公共服务书评。”
The Times didn't run it, but it did run in Adweek , though toward the back of the magazine, and it got no response.
《时报》没有刊登，但它在《广告周刊》上登了，尽管是在杂志后面，而且没有得到任何回应。
Over the years, he and some of his former colleagues have written to reporters at the New York Times and other places trying to correct the record, but their letters have mostly been ignored. Just last year, a Times story about an exhibit of George Lois' Esquire covers credited him in the very first paragraph with "Think Small," the Xerox ads with the chimp, and a couple of other campaigns people say George either didn't originate or didn't even work on. Finally, the Times printed a short correction, giving "Think Small" back to my dad, but it was a small victory three weeks after the fact.
多年来，他和一些前同事写信给《纽约时报》和其他地方的记者，试图纠正记录，但他们的信大多被忽视了。就在去年，一篇关于乔治·洛伊斯《时尚先生》封面展览的《时报》文章，在第一段就归功于他创作了“想想小”、带有黑猩猩的施乐广告，以及人们说乔治要么没策划要么根本没参与的其他几个广告活动。最终，《时报》刊登了一则简短的更正，把“想想小”还给了我父亲，但这已经是事实发生三周后的一场小胜利。
In the mid '80s, my dad wrote a letter to George directly, threatening to sue, it seems, and received a letter back calling him a sad, tortured and tragic figure.
80年代中期，我父亲直接写信给乔治，似乎威胁要起诉，并收到了一封回信，称他为一个悲伤、痛苦和悲剧性的人物。
All in all, my father's efforts haven't really done the damage he's hoped or really any damage at all. He's an indignant Basset Hound, nipping at the heels of the media's Great Dane. George Lois is a good talker with an engaging personality, and he's become something of a spokesman for the advertising industry. There are quotes in the newspaper and magazine profiles, exhibits, books. Errors printed once are repeated and repeated. So if you look up "Think Small" on the internet, for instance, you'll find it attributed to Julian Koenig, but you're also likely to learn that George Lois wrote it.
总而言之，我父亲的努力并没有真正造成他所希望的损害，或者说根本没有任何损害。他是一只义愤填膺的巴吉度猎犬，在媒体这只大丹犬的脚后跟边吠叫。乔治·洛伊斯是一个善谈的人，个性迷人，他已经成为了广告业的某种代言人。报纸和杂志的简介、展览、书籍中都有他的引述。错误一旦印出来就会被反复重复。所以如果你在互联网上查找“想想小”，你会发现它归功于朱利安·科尼格，但也很有可能了解到是乔治·洛伊斯写的。
I like the way he took credit for accounts he never had anything to do with, because that made it almost comical. All the Xerox stuff, Xerox stuff in the account that I got, was done by Sam Scali and I think Mike Chappell, and George at the end started taking credit for that, too.
我喜欢他为那些他根本没参与过的客户抢功的方式，因为那让它几乎变得滑稽了。所有的施乐广告，我得到的那些施乐广告，都是萨姆·斯卡利和我想迈克·查佩尔做的，乔治在最后也开始为此抢功。
That's Fred Papert, the P of PKL. He was the guy who recruited Lois and Koenig to make a new agency in 1960. Now he's one of the guys responsible for redeveloping Times Square as president of the 42nd Street Development Corporation. He knows the stories all too well: Xerox, Harvey Probber, Coldene, Ernie Kovacs even.
那是弗雷德·帕佩特，PKL中的P。他就是那个在1960年招募洛伊斯和科尼格创建新代理公司的人。现在他是作为第42街开发公司总裁负责重新开发时代广场的人之一。他太了解这些故事了：施乐、哈维·普罗伯、Coldene，甚至是厄尼·科瓦克斯。
It's nuts. I think he's really got a screw loose. I think George truly doesn't know what he's doing. But it's nutty on both sides.
太疯狂了。我觉得他的脑袋真的有点毛病。我觉得乔治是真的不知道自己在做什么。但这在双方身上都是疯狂的。
Fred's in my dad's camp insofar as he knows and believes my dad is telling the truth. But his support more or less stops there. And he's categorical on this point, that my dad is himself acting like a nut, wasting his time. They've talked about this on rides to and from the racetrack.
弗雷德在我父亲的阵营里，因为他知道并相信我父亲说的是真话。但他的支持也就到此为止了。他对此非常明确，我父亲自己也像个疯子一样在浪费时间。他们已经在去赛马场的路上谈论过这件事了。
The reason that Julian should not be fussing about this stuff at this stage is A, nobody gives a [BLEEP]. B, anybody that would give a [BLEEP] knows already what it's about because this is what George does. It's George's thing. They've just got to put a  lid on it.
朱利安在这个阶段不应该为这些事大惊小怪的原因是，A，没人会在意。B，任何会在意的人都已经知道是怎么回事了，因为这就是乔治的风格。这是乔治的套路。他们只需要闭嘴就行了。
But I've had this conversation with him 100 times, and he gets really pissed off, so I know he's got a screw loose, too. Your father can be a pain in the ass, you know. And even be testy if you say to him, Julian, [BLEEP] off already. We've heard this story, and we know about the wobbling chair or the wobbling floor. I've forgotten which one. You have no idea how many letters we wrote to the New York Times, to Advertising Age , to this and that. This is a dialogue between old farts.
但我已经和他谈过100次这种对话了，他真的会很火大，所以我知道他的脑袋也有点毛病。你父亲有时真让人头疼。如果你跟他说，朱利安，滚一边去吧，我们已经听过这个故事了，我们知道摇晃的椅子或摇晃的地板的事儿。我已经忘了是哪个了，他甚至会变得脾气暴躁。你不知道我们写了多少封信给《纽约时报》、《广告时代》等等。这是一场老头子之间的对话。
Julian's in another world from these kinds of things. Julian is one of the great thinkers and creators in the advertising business. If some nutcase claims credit, who cares? And he doesn't even really like me very much. You have to understand that that's where we start. Well, it's true. I think he goes to the races with me because I have a car.
朱利安在这些事情上处于另一个世界。朱利安是广告界伟大的思想家和创造者之一。如果一些疯子要抢功，谁会在乎呢？而且他甚至不怎么喜欢我。你必须明白这就是我们的起点。好吧，这是真的。我想他跟我去赛马是因为我有车。
My father recognizes that there are only about four people left on Earth who care about this stuff. It's just that he happens to be one of them, and he cannot let it go.
我父亲承认地球上只剩下大约四个人在意这些事情了。只是恰好他是其中之一，他无法放手。
I assume if I had a different personality, I would I say I know what I've done. And those dear and near to me know what I have done or not done, and I'm OK with that. But I'm a fallible fellow, obviously with ego of his own, and I resent being burgled.
我想如果我是不同的性格，我会说我知道我做了什么。那些亲近我的人知道我做了什么或没做什么，我对此感到没问题。但我是一个易犯错的人，显然有他自己的自负，我很反感被盗窃。
The odd thing about all this, as my older brother John points out, is that my father has never exactly been a champion of advertising.
这一切奇怪的地方，正如我哥哥约翰指出的，是我父亲从来没有完全成为广告业的拥护者。
And he never believed he didn't have a-- he wasn't a true believer in the business. I mean, I remember him saying to me as a kid, you know, if you don't find something you want to do and really work at it, you're going to end up like me: a writer of short sentences. That's verbatim. And so, it's a little ironic, you know? Because he didn't care. That's the thing, Sarah. You know, all those years he didn't care, because I think he thought it was beneath him. And the business in some ways was not beneath him but was not serious enough to care that much about. And now he does.
他从不相信他没有——他不是这个行业的真正信徒。我的意思是，我记得我小时候他对我说的，你知道，如果你不找一件你想做并真正为此努力的事，你最终会像我一样：写短句。那是原文。所以，这有点讽刺，不是吗？因为他不在乎。就是这样，莎拉。你知道，那些年他都不在乎，因为我认为他觉得这太屈尊了。而这个行业在某种程度上对他来说并不屈尊，但也没有认真到让他那么在意。而现在他在意了。
I understand why he cares. He's 88 years old now, so his legacy, understandably, is on his mind. And even though he did campaigns for all sorts of good causes-- gun control, nuclear proliferation, Robert Kennedy's senatorial and presidential campaigns-- my father's not quite satisfied with his life's work.
我明白他为什么在意。他现在88岁了，所以遗产问题，可以理解，就在他心头。尽管他为各种公益事业——枪支管制、核扩散、罗伯特·肯尼迪的参议院和总统竞选——做了广告活动，但我父亲对自己一生的工作并不完全满意。
Advertising is built on puffery, and, at heart, deception, and I don't think anybody can go proudly into the next world with a career built on deception, even though no matter how well they do it.
广告是建立在吹嘘，而且本质上是欺骗的基础上的，我不认为任何人能带着一个建立在欺骗之上的职业生涯自豪地进入下一个世界，无论他们做得多好。
You're not necessarily proud that you had a career in the field of advertising and that's your legacy, but you are proud that you were the best in the business at the thing you chose to do.
你不一定因为你在广告领域有职业生涯而自豪，以此作为你的遗产，但你确实自豪于你是你选择从事的事情中业界最棒的。
I couldn't have said it better myself.
我自己都说不出更好的话了。
If he could go back, choose another career, my father would have liked to have been an environmentalist of some kind, which is why he'd really like to be remembered for something almost nobody knows he did: naming Earth Day. It agitated him to look up Earth Day on Wikipedia recently and not see his name anywhere. So a few days ago, I added it.
如果能回去，选择另一个职业，我父亲会想成为某种环保主义者，这就是为什么他真的很想被记住一些几乎没人知道他做过的事：命名地球日。最近在维基百科上查找地球日却没看到他的名字，这让他感到不安。所以几天前，我加上去了。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our program.
莎拉·科尼格是我们节目的制作人之一。
Coming up, a dead man's kid versus the US Supreme Court. That's in a minute. Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个死人的孩子与美国最高法院的对抗。一分钟后。芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week  on our show, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show: origin stories, where we go back to figure out where things came from.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并带给你关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目：起源故事，我们回顾过去以弄清楚事物来自哪里。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, The Secret Life of Secrets.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，秘密的秘密生活。
This week, when the Attorney General appeared before the Senate Judiciary Committee, he told them that any day now, he'll be delivering the Administration take on how to change the state secrets privilege. And I don't know about you, but for me, every time this comes up in the news, I have to be reminded what the hell the state secrets privilege actually is in the first place. And every time I read about it and relearn it, I think to myself, oh, right. That's one of those legal things that anybody can understand.
这周，当司法部长出现在参议院司法委员会面前时，他告诉他们，随时他都会提交政府关于如何改变国家机密特权的看法。我不知道你怎么想，但对我来说，每当这出现在新闻中，我都得被提醒一下，到底什么是国家机密特权。每次我读到它并重新学习它时，我都会对自己说，哦，对了。那是那种任何人都能理解的法律常识之一。
Basically, it's this: If you are suing the US Government, the Government can claim that taking your case to court would reveal sensitive national security information. If they do that, simply by making that claim, they can get your case thrown out of court. The judge won't even usually look at the evidence to see if the Government is fibbing.
基本上，它是这样的：如果你正在起诉美国政府，政府可以声称将你的案件提交法庭会泄露敏感的国家安全信息。如果他们那样做，仅仅通过提出那个声明，他们就能让你的案件被法院驳回。法官通常甚至不会查看证据来看看政府是否在撒谎。
Democrat and Republican presidents have both used this to get all kinds of cases dismissed. Under the Bush administration, this increased dramatically. They got judges to throw out lawsuits regarding the torture and rendition of detainees in the War on Terror, over Guantanamo, over the wiretapping of American citizens.
民主党和共和党总统都利用这一点驳回了各种案件。在布什政府领导下，这种情况急剧增加。他们让法官驳回了关于反恐战争中被拘留者的酷刑和引渡、关塔那摩以及监听美国公民的诉讼。
Yeah, well, the state secrets privilege came about as a result of a 1953 Supreme Court decision, US v. Reynolds.
是的，好吧，国家机密特权是1953年最高法院裁决《美国诉雷诺兹案》的结果。
This is Barry Siegel, a reporter who wrote about the true story of US v. Reynolds for the LA Times and later in a book called Claim of Privilege. It is very possible that if we could somehow send his book back in time to the year 1953 and let the Supreme Court justices read what really happened in US v. Reynolds, they would have decided the case differently. Some important facts have come to light in the last half century about the case.
这是巴里·西格尔，一位为《洛杉矶时报》撰写了《美国诉雷诺兹案》真实故事的记者，后来又写了一本名为《特权主张》的书。如果我们将他的书送回到1953年，让最高法院法官读到《美国诉雷诺兹案》中真正发生了什么，他们很可能会做出不同的判决。在过去半个世纪里，关于该案的一些重要事实已经浮出水面。
As a public service right now, in case any of you hearing my voice do someday get teleported back to the year 1953, we present now the true origin of US v. Reynolds.
作为一项公共服务，现在，如果你们中有人听到我的声音，有一天确实被传送回1953年，我们现在展示《美国诉雷诺兹案》的真正起源。
A US Air Force B-29 in October 1948 took off in Georgia to test an experimental navigation system, radar system. Three civilian engineers from RCA were onboard as part of the test team. The plane engines caught fire. The plane crashed over Waycross, Georgia, October 6, 1948.
1948年10月，一架美国空军B-29飞机在佐治亚州起飞，测试一种实验性导航系统、雷达系统。来自美国无线电公司（RCA）的三名平民工程师作为测试团队成员在机上。飞机引擎起火。飞机于1948年10月6日在佐治亚州韦克罗斯坠毁。
The widows of the three civilian engineers onboard sued the Government: negligence. During discovery process, the widows asked for the Air Force accident report. The Government wouldn't turn it over, wouldn't turn over the accident report. A Federal District judge, a very brave one, William Kirkpatrick, who was hearing the case, ordered the Government to produce the document. He said you can just turn it over to me in private. I'll look at it in chambers. The Government wouldn't hand it over even to the judge to look at in private in chambers.
机上三名平民工程师的遗孀起诉政府：疏忽。在取证过程中，遗孀们索要空军事故报告。政府不会移交，不会移交事故报告。一名联邦地方法官，一位非常勇敢的法官，威廉·柯克帕特里克，负责审理此案，命令政府出示该文件。他说你可以私下交给我。我会私下查看。政府甚至不愿把文件交给法官私下查看。
Because the Government would not comply with his order to turn over the accident report, the judge declares the widows the winners in this case by default. An appeals court agrees. It gets to the Supreme Court, whose decision you already know. It overturns the lower two courts, finds in favor of the Government, says the Government does not have to hand over the accident report once it claims that this would reveal state secrets.
因为政府不遵守他移交事故报告的命令，法官默认裁定遗孀们在案件中胜诉。上诉法院表示同意。案件到了最高法院，你已经知道他们的判决了。它推翻了下级法院的判决，裁定政府胜诉，说政府一旦声称这将泄露国家机密，就不必移交事故报告。
But understand what happens next. There's an important thing you need to keep in mind about this Supreme Court decision.
但请明白接下来发生了什么。关于这个最高法院判决，有一件重要的事情你需要记住。
Keep in mind, in 1953, the Supreme Court in ruling for the Government never itself asked to see the accident report. It voted in 1953 to believe the Government when it said it contained state secrets. And that's the foundation for the whole state secrets privilege in US v. Reynolds . It says that we have to trust the Government. If they can convince us that national security is at risk, then you don't have to even ask for the documents. So they never saw it. No one ever saw the accident report back then.
记住，1953年，最高法院在为政府裁决时，它自己从未看过那份事故报告。它在1953年投票相信政府，当政府声称其中包含国家机密时。这就是《美国诉雷诺兹案》中整个国家机密特权的基础。它说我们必须信任政府。如果他们能说服我们国家安全处于危险之中，那么你甚至不必索要文件。所以他们从来没看过。当时没有人看过那份事故报告。
So 50 years passed. The families of these three civilians who had perished in the plane, they tried for years to find out more of what happened on that plane. They never could. The children of the engineers, who really never knew their fathers, always wondered who they were and what had happened to them. One of them particularly, Judy Loether, she was seven weeks old when her father Al Palya died.
于是50年过去了。在飞机失事中遇难的这三名平民的家人，多年来试图查明飞机上到底发生了什么。他们从未做到。那些工程师的孩子们，从来没真正了解他们的父亲，总是想知道他们是谁，发生了什么。其中一个特别的人，朱迪·洛瑟，她父亲阿尔·帕利亚去世时她才七周大。
I knew my father had died in a plane crash, and I knew it was an Air Force plane, and I knew that there was a secret project.
我知道我父亲死于坠机，我知道那是空军飞机，我知道有一个秘密项目。
This is Judy Loether. Now, of course, she's grown. She lives in a town not far from Boston.
这是朱迪·洛瑟。现在，当然，她长大了。她住在波士顿附近的一个镇上。
The biggest question I had was what secret project were they doing on that plane? I mean, you know, what did my father die for?
我最大的问题是他们在飞机上到底在做什么秘密项目？我的意思是，你知道，我父亲为什么而死？
Over the years, she'd go into little spurts of looking into this. She exchanged letters with a man who had survived the crash. She went through her father's old papers and technical manuals. And then in the late 1990s, she got a computer and started searching the internet. She learned all about B-29s and about the bomb site device that her dad worked on as an engineer. It made her feel closer to him to see pictures of these things that he had made. She printed stuff out. She kept it in a notebook. And then one night in February 2000, she sat down at a computer.
多年来，她会断断续续地调查这件事。她与一名坠机幸存者交换了信件。她翻阅了父亲的旧文件和技术手册。然后在90年代末，她有了一台电脑并开始在网上搜索。她了解了所有关于B-29的信息，以及她父亲作为工程师参与的轰炸瞄准器设备。看到他制造的这些东西的照片让她感觉离他更近。她把东西打印出来。她把它保存在一个笔记本里。然后在2000年2月的一天晚上，她坐在电脑前。
And again, my cursor was on that blank box. And I said, well, what do I want to look up tonight? And for the first time, I typed in the combination of B-29 plus accident, and I had never done that before. And the first hit was accidentreport.com. And this page comes up. Accident reports from military crashes from 1918 through 1955.
再一次，我的光标停在那空白框上。我说，好吧，今晚我想查找什么？这是第一次，我输入了B-29加坠机这个组合，我以前从未做过。第一个结果是accidentreport.com。这个页面出来了。1918年至1955年军事坠机事故报告。
All of these reports had been declassified in the 1990s.
所有这些报告在90年代都被解密了。
And I remember looking at those words and reading them like three times and thinking 1948. Wow! This place is going to have the report of that plane crash?
我记得看着那些字，读了三遍，心里想着1948。哇！这个地方会有那场坠机事故的报告？
Now, at the time, did you know that this report had been the subject of a lawsuit and that the Government refused to give your mom and the other widows this very accident report that suddenly you're actually able to get from this guy for $60-something?
当时，你知道这份报告曾是诉讼的对象，政府拒绝把你妈妈和其他遗孀索要的这份事故报告——你现在突然能从这个人那里以60多美元买到——给她们吗？
I hadn't a clue. I knew there had been a lawsuit, but that's all I knew.
我一点头绪都没有。我知道曾有过诉讼，但我只知道这么多。
And did you know that the lawsuit turned into this famous Supreme Court precedent?
你知道那场诉讼演变成了著名的最高法院先例吗？
No. I had no idea.
不知道。我完全不知道。
Two weeks later, Judy Loether gets mail from him, this accident report that her mom and the other widows had vainly sought 50 years before. And what's interesting about this is that she's kind of disappointed when she pulls out the accident report because she's not looking for the cause of the accident. What she really wants to know is what the secret thing was that her dad was doing on that plane. It was just a way to get to know about her dad. And to her great frustration, when she pulls out the accident report and reads it is that there's no reference at all to the secret project her father was working on.
两周后，朱迪·洛瑟收到了他的邮件，就是她妈妈和其他遗孀50年前徒劳索要的那份事故报告。有趣的是，当她拿出事故报告时，她有点失望，因为她不是在寻找事故原因。她真正想知道的是她父亲在飞机上做的那个秘密东西是什么。那只是她了解父亲的一种方式。令她极度沮丧的是，当她拿出事故报告阅读时，里面根本没有提到她父亲正在进行的秘密项目。
There was nothing in there about the secret equipment or the secret mission of the plane other than the mention that there was secret equipment on the plane. And that, of course, was in the newspapers.
除了提到飞机上有秘密设备外，里面没有任何关于秘密设备或飞机秘密任务的内容。当然，这在报纸上已经提到过了。
Instead of that stuff, what was in the accident report was a stark, very detailed account of Air Force negligence. There was a lot of negligence. This particular B-29 had a history of trouble: fuel leaks, faulty engines. It had been repeatedly grounded. The engines on all B-29s had a tendency to overheat and were supposed to get special heat shields installed to fix that, but this plane never got them. On this flight, the engines caught fire, and the pilot made some errors that compounded that problem and sent the plane into a spin.
取而代之的是，事故报告中是一份极其详细的、关于空军疏忽的记录。那里有许多疏忽。这架B-29本身就有故障史：燃油泄漏、引擎故障。它被反复停飞。所有B-29的引擎都有过热倾向，本应安装特殊的隔热罩来修复，但那架飞机从没装过。在这次飞行中，引擎起火，飞行员犯了一些加剧问题的错误，使飞机进入了旋转。
Disturbed and saddened, Judy thought that she should share this document with other families from the crash, and from newspaper clippings, she learned of another woman whose father died that day: Susan Brauner. When she met Brauner, it was Brauner who told her about the Supreme Court decision.
感到不安和悲伤，朱迪觉得她应该把这份文件分享给其他坠机遇难者的家人，通过剪报，她了解到了那天父亲去世的另一位女性：苏珊·布劳纳。当她见到布劳纳时，是布劳纳告诉她最高法院判决的事。
Within a half an hour of when I got home, I was reading that decision. And it was that moment, as I'm reading through the decision and it's all hinging on this accident report which I have, and I'm reading it, and the justices are saying in their decision it's a reasonable assumption that this accident report talks about the secret equipment and the secret mission, and I'm saying no. No, it doesn't talk about that at all. I couldn't understand it. It just really upset me. And then I think the fact that Reynolds was being used over and over again by the Government, it was such an important case, and it was based on this lie.
在我到家后半小时内，我就在读那个判决了。就在那一刻，当我读着判决书，它全部基于我手中的这份事故报告，而法官在他们的判决中说，这是一个合理的假设：事故报告谈到了秘密设备和秘密任务，但我说不对。不，它根本没谈到那些。我无法理解。它真的让我很心烦。然后我想，雷诺兹案被政府一次又一次地使用，它是一个如此重要的案件，而它是建立在谎言之上的，这个事实让人难受。
In his reporting, Barry Siegel lists some of the other kinds of cases that have fallen under the state secrets privilege since this precedent was set. "In 1990," he writes, "families of 37 crew members who were killed by Iraqi missiles hitting the USS Stark sued the contractors responsible for the ship's antimissile system. The Government said trying the case would reveal state secrets, and this got it thrown out of court.
在报道中，巴里·西格尔列出了一些自该先例确立以来落入国家机密特权范畴的其他案件。“1990年，”他写道，“因伊拉克导弹击中斯塔克号（USS Stark）而死亡的37名船员的家属起诉了负责该舰反导系统的承包商。政府表示审理该案会泄露国家机密，案件因此被法院驳回。”
In 2000, a CIA employee sued the agency for gender discrimination. The Government said trying the case would reveal state secrets, and this got it thrown out of court.
“2000年，一名中情局员工起诉该机构存在性别歧视。政府表示审理该案会泄露国家机密，案件因此被法院驳回。”
In 2003, a senior engineer said a Defense contractor had submitted false test results on an antimissile vehicle. The Government said trying this case would reveal state secrets and got that thrown out of court."
“2003年，一名高级工程师称一家国防承包商提交了关于反导车辆的虚假测试结果。政府表示审理该案会泄露国家机密，因此被法院驳回。”
And so, Siegel says, "Its disturbing that in the case that made all this possible-- US v. Reynolds-- the Government said that it couldn't turn over an accident report because this would reveal state secrets. But there seemed to be no state secrets at all in the accident report. At that point, it wasn't even a secret that B-29s were having these terrible mechanical problems.
所以，西格尔说，“令人不安的是，在使这一切成为可能的案件——美国诉雷诺兹案中——政府说它不能移交事故报告，因为这将泄露国家机密。但在事故报告中似乎根本没有任何国家机密。那时，B-29正面临这些可怕的机械问题甚至都不是秘密。”
It's really interesting, US v. Reynolds based on a lie. The very case that establishes the right of the state secrets privilege is a perfect example of why the Government shouldn't have that privilege.
这真的很有趣，美国诉雷诺兹案是建立在一个谎言之上的。确立国家机密特权权利的那个案子，本身就是为什么政府不应该拥有该特权的一个完美例子。
As for Judy, the more she thought about it, the more she was bothered by the fact that the Government's lawyers back in the 1950s must have read the accident report themselves, so they must have known that the Air Force was negligent. But when the lower courts found them negligent and awarded the widows some money, these Government lawyers kept appealing that decision, all the way up to the Supreme Court.
至于朱迪，她越想就越感到困扰，因为20世纪50年代政府的律师一定自己读过事故报告，所以他们一定知道空军有疏忽。但当下级法院发现他们有疏忽并给遗孀们赔偿一些钱时，这些政府律师一直上诉那个判决，一路诉到了最高法院。
That again is disturbing to me, because it's not like they were some corporation. These were three widows whose husbands were dead because of their negligence, but they were going to get their precedent at our cost.
这一点再次让我感到不安，因为他们不是什么大公司。这是三位遗孀，她们的丈夫因为他们的疏忽而死了，但他们却要以我们的代价来确立他们的先例。
So Judy and two other families from the crash went back to the Philadelphia law firm that had originally represented her mom and the other widows back in 1953. And together, they filed a new petition in the Supreme Court. Not asking that US v. Reynolds cease to be a precedent. Too many other cases had agreed with the finding in Reynolds that that wasn't really an option. And the goal wasn't to overturn the state secrets privilege. Instead, they wanted the court to acknowledge that the Government had lied about the contents of the accident report, that the Government had committed fraud before the Supreme Court, and they wanted the court to award monetary damages that should have gone to the widows back then.
所以朱迪和坠机事故中的另外两个家庭回到了1953年最初代表她母亲和其他遗孀的费城律师事务所。他们一起在最高法院提交了一份新的请愿书。并不是要求《美国诉雷诺兹案》不再作为先例。太多其他案件已经同意了雷诺兹案的发现，这不是一个真正可选的方案。他们的目标也不是推翻国家机密特权。相反，他们希望法院承认政府在事故报告的内容上撒了谎，政府在最高法院面前犯了欺诈罪，他们希望法院裁定当初本应给予遗孀们的金钱赔偿。
This gets a little technical into the legal, but the Supreme Court invited the Solicitor General--
这在法律上变得有点技术性，但最高法院邀请了副总检察长——
The Solicitor General, of course, the administration's lawyer who deals with the Supreme Court.
副总检察长，当然，是处理最高法院事务的政府律师。
--to respond to this petition. And the Solicitor General's argument essentially said we are not in a position now, us sitting here 50 years later, to know why the Air Force made a state secrets claim. We're not experts, and we can't know what their reasons were 50 years before.
——来回应这份请愿书。而副总检察长的论点本质上说，我们现在身处50年后，无法知道空军为什么要提出国家机密主张。我们不是专家，我们无法知道他们50年前的理由是什么。
The Supreme Court declined to hear the case.
最高法院拒绝受理此案。
So even though the Supreme Court refused to take this case, can their petition have an effect on the law in some way? Can it be cited? Has it been cited?
所以尽管最高法院拒绝受理此案，他们的请愿能在某种程度上对法律产生影响吗？它可以被引用吗？它被引用过吗？
Yes. That's exactly what their legacy is. I think that they didn't prevail in the Supreme Court. They prevailed in the two ways that they probably most were seeking some effect. First of all, they sure got their story out. And the other thing that they did is that lawyers now involved in litigation with the Government have started to talk about the origins of the US v. Reynolds decision. Now when the Government waives the state secrets flag in court, the other side can get up and say, well, wait a second. And it has happened.
是的。这正是他们的遗产所在。我认为尽管他们在最高法院没能胜诉。但他们在他们最寻求效果的两个方面可能取得了胜利。首先，他们确实把他们的故事传出去了。另一件他们做的事是，现在涉及政府诉讼的律师已经开始讨论《美国诉雷诺兹案》判决的起源了。现在当政府在法庭上挥舞国家机密旗帜时，另一方可以站起来说，嘿，等一下。这种情况已经发生了。
I can tell you there was a recent Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals decision, which finally-- one of the few rare ones, which did limit a Government state secrets claim.
我可以告诉你，最近有一个第九巡回上诉法院的判决，最终——这是少数罕见的情况之一，确实限制了政府的国家机密主张。
The court said, in this case, that they wouldn't just take the Government's word about whether there were secrets in the documents being discussed. The Government would have to show the documents to the judges, one by one, in private.
法院在那个案件中说，他们不会仅仅接受政府关于被讨论的文件中是否有秘密的说法。政府必须一个个私下向法官展示文件。
In this decision in the Ninth Circuit, which just came out in the last few weeks, there was a footnote in which these appellate judges cited what you and I are talking about today. They cited the fact that US v. Reynolds-- it said the dubious origins of US v. Reynolds.
在第九巡回法院最近几周刚刚出炉的这个判决中，有一个脚注，这些上诉法官引用了你我今天正在讨论的内容。他们引用了这样一个事实，即《美国诉雷诺兹案》——它提到了《美国诉雷诺兹案》的可疑起源。
In 2008, Judy Loether testified before Congress. And when Senators Edward Kennedy and then Republican Arlen Specter introduced a bill to regulate the state secrets privilege once and for all, a bill that would tell judges not just to take the Government's word when it claims that a state secret is involved in the case, but actually look at the evidence to be sure that it's true, they cited what happened in Reynolds.
2008年，朱迪·洛瑟在国会作证。当参议员爱德华·肯尼迪和共和党人阿伦·斯佩克特引入一项法案，最终规范国家机密特权时——一项告诉法官不要在政府声称案件涉及国家机密时仅仅听信其一面之词，而是实际查看证据以确保真实性的法案——他们引用了雷诺兹案中发生的事情。
This is from the press release, quote: "Recently declassified information about the Supreme Court's leading decision on the state secrets privilege-- US v. Reynolds-- provides an early example of executive abuse of the privilege. That kind of abuse will no longer be possible under the State Secrets Protection Act."
这是来自新闻稿，引述：“关于最高法院关于国家机密特权的主导判决——《美国诉雷诺兹案》的最新解密信息——提供了行政部门滥用特权的一个早期例子。在《国家机密保护法》下，那种滥用将不再可能发生。”
A version of the bill came out of a House subcommittee this week. The bill's on the schedule to be marked up next week by the Senate Judiciary Committee.
该法案的一个版本本周已从众议院小组委员会出炉。该法案定于下周由参议院司法委员会审议。
[MUSIC - "FRIENDS AND ANCESTORS" BY NEDELLE]
[音乐 - NEDELLE的“朋友和祖先”]
Act Three. Wait Wait-- Don't Film Me.
第三幕。等等等等——别拍我。
Now, this origin story. Our colleague at WBEZ and the host of the public radio show Wait Wait-- Don't Tell Me!, Mr. Peter Sagal, used to be a playwright. And to give you a sense of the kind of work that he did as a playwright, his most successful play, he says, was about a Holocaust denier and the Jewish attorney who represented that Holocaust denier in court.
现在，这个起源故事。我们在WBEZ的同事和公共广播节目《等等等等——别告诉我！》的主持人，彼得·萨加尔先生，曾经是一位剧作家。为了让你感受到他作为剧作家所做作品的风格，他说，他最成功的剧本是关于一个大屠杀否认者和在法庭上为那个大屠杀否认者辩护的犹太律师的。
And so it was all intellectual arguments and drama and involved the Holocaust and questions of the First Amendment law. And it came to the attention of this producer Lawrence Bender, who is most well known for being Quentin Tarantino's producer. So he produced, among many other movies, Reservoir Dogs and Pulp Fiction and so on and so forth.
那是关于所有智力辩论、戏剧冲突，涉及到大屠杀和第一修正案法律的问题。它引起了制片人劳伦斯·本德的注意，他最出名的是作为昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的制片人。所以他制作了许多电影，其中包括《落水狗》、《低俗小说》等等。
Back in the '90s when all this happened, Bender read Peter's play and liked it and called him up and asked Peter if he wanted to write a movie. And Peter basically had been waiting for this phone call from Hollywood forever.
90年代这一切发生时，本德读了彼得的剧本，很喜欢，于是打电话给彼得，问彼得是否想写一部电影。彼得基本上一直在等待好莱坞的这个电话。
I mean, I think in the year 1992, my annual income was $10,000. Yeah, this was the phone call that you wait for.
我的意思是，我想在1992年，我的年收入是10,000美元。是的，这就是你等待的那个电话。
So after tossing around some different ideas for this film, Lawrence Bender introduces Peter to this woman who he works with, who at 15 had been an American in Cuba when the Cuban Revolution happened. Maybe there's a film in that. So Peter starts writing this film that's half romance, growing-up film, half politics about an American teenage girl in Cuba in the '50s.
所以在为这部电影抛出一些不同的点子后，劳伦斯·本德向彼得介绍了与他一起工作的这位女士，她在15岁时是古巴革命发生时在古巴的美国人。也许那里面有一部电影。所以彼得开始写这部电影，一半是浪漫，成长电影，一半是关于50年代古巴的美国少女的政治。
And I had no-- I didn't know anything about the Cuban Revolution. But one of the things I found out was that everybody involved with it was incredibly young. Castro himself was only 29. They were all 17, 18, 19, 20 years old, these guys up in the mountains with him. And one of the things that actually happened was almost as soon as they took over, the Cuban Revolution, these wonderful young Democrats, freedom-loving rebels from the mountains, started executing people on television.
而且我没有——我当时对古巴革命一无所知。但我发现的事情之一是参与其中的每个人都非常年轻。卡斯特罗本人只有29岁。他们都是17、18、19、20岁，这些家伙和他一起在山上。而实际上发生的其中一件事是，几乎在他们接管古巴革命后，这些奇妙的年轻民主党人、来自山上的热爱自由的叛军，开始在电视上处决人。
And in my original conception, there were two parallel stories. There was Maria, who I called the central character, who had a rebellious-- more typically adolescent rebellion going against her own parents. And then there was her romantic interest, a character named Josefo, who was a Cuban and was sort of a third-column rebel underground guy, living and working in Havana to undermine the regime, sometimes through violence.
在我的最初构思中，有两条平行的故事线。一个是玛丽亚，我称她为中心人物，她有一种叛逆——更典型的青春期反叛，违抗她自己的父母。另一个是她的浪漫对象，一个名叫何塞福的角色，他是一个古巴人，是某种第三纵队叛军地下成员，在哈瓦那生活和工作以破坏政权，有时通过暴力。
And eventually this film did get made and--
最终这部电影确实被拍了出来，而且——
It did.
确实。
It did. It finally got made a bit later, and I'm just going to play a clip here from it.
确实。它后来终于被拍出来了，我打算放一段里面的片段。
Oh God! I love dancing with him.
哦上帝！我喜欢和他跳舞。
Did it ever occur to you that that boy might be using you? A nice American girl--
你有没有想过那个男孩可能在利用你？一个好的美国女孩——
No.
不。
-- who can be his ticket out.
——谁能成为他离开的门票。
Please, no. That's not true.
拜托，不。那不是真的。
You may love dancing with that boy, but there are more important factors here like your family and your future!
你可能喜欢和那个男孩跳舞，但这里有更重要的因素，比如你的家庭和你的未来！
Why does it have to be either/or? Just because you gave up your passion, why should I? [SLAP]
为什么必须是二选一？仅仅因为你放弃了你的激情，我为什么要放弃？ [打耳光]
So that's a clip from the film. You want to just let people know the title of the film?
这就是电影中的一个片段。你想让人们知道这部电影的标题吗？
The title of the film is Dirty Dancing 2-- colon-- Havana Nights.
这部电影的标题是《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》。
Now, I have to say, I watched the movie last night. I watched Dirty Dancing 2--
现在，我必须说，我昨晚看了那部电影。我看了《辣身舞2》——
The whole thing?
全看了？
Yeah.
是的。
There is not a single line of dialogue in that movie that I wrote.
那部电影里没有一行我写的台词。
So how does a film go from political coming-of-age drama to Dirty Dancing 2: Havana Nights? Well, of course, it's an old Hollywood story. Peter writes his film. He turns it in. They ask him to make it more like-- oh, maybe could it be more like Dirty Dancing? Innocent girl with a semi-dangerous guy?
那么一部电影是如何从政治成长戏剧变成《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》的呢？好吧，当然，这是一个老掉牙的好莱坞故事。彼得写了他的电影。他交上去了。他们要求他让它更像——哦，也许能不能更像《辣身舞》？清纯女孩和半危险的家伙？
And sometimes I think back on the experience, and I say, you know, I should have said to them, hey, if that's what you want, I'm really not the guy for it.
有时我回想那段经历，我说，你知道，我应该对他们说，嘿，如果那是你想要的，我真的不是合适的人选。
He says each draft got worse and worse. Even he didn't like it. Finally, it was shelved. Years later, the producer who actually owned the rights to the film Dirty Dancing teamed up with Lawrence Bender to make a sequel, and somebody thought of Peter's old script. All the politics of the film got reduced to this one moment where, really, unconnected to anything else in the film, somebody attempts to shoot some unidentified political figure at the climax of the dance contest. And then later in a moment of obligatory foreshadowing, our couple talks about whether Castro would ever kick out Americans from Cuba.
他说每一稿都变得越来越糟。连他自己都不喜欢。最终，它被搁置了。多年后，实际拥有《辣身舞》电影版权的制片人与劳伦斯·本德联手制作续集，有人想到了彼得的旧剧本。电影的所有政治内涵被简化为这一个时刻，也就是，真的，与电影中其他任何东西都不相关，有人试图在舞蹈比赛的高潮处射杀某个身份不明的政治人物。然后在稍后一个强制性的伏笔时刻，我们的情侣谈论卡斯特罗是否会将美国人赶出古巴。
I'm just saying that--
我只是说——
What? that I might have to leave?
什么？我可能得离开？
Could happen.
可能会发生。
But they wouldn't do that. Not if the whole idea is to give people their freedom.
但他们不会那样做。如果整个想法是给予人们自由的话。
Can I ask you what it was like for you to watch the film? For you to sit in a theater and watch the film?
我能问问你坐在电影院看这部电影是什么感觉吗？
It was fine. It was really fine. Because--
挺好的。真的挺好的。因为——
Oh, honey.
哦，亲爱的。
No, no, no. I mean this. Let me put it this way. Before I got that call, this experience had been a failure. I mean, I remember at that time just lying in bed, going, well, I had my shot and I blew it. All I ever wanted was a shot. I got my shot and it failed. I did a bad job. And so then when I got the phone call, it's like, oh, it's going to be made, and it's going to be Dirty Dancing 2. That's a happy ending. That's a much better ending than the ending I thought I had, which was that it was just a disaster.
不，不，不。我是认真的。让我这样说吧。在接到那个电话之前，这段经历一直是一个失败。我的意思是，我记得当时躺在床上想着，好吧，我有机会了我把它搞砸了。我唯一想要的就是机会。我得到了机会，但它失败了。我做得很差。所以当我接到那个电话时，就像是，哦，它要被拍出来了，而且它是《辣身舞2》。那是一个快乐的结局。那比我原以为的结局好多了，那是一个灾难。
Act  Four. Bill Clinton's 7-Year-Old Brother.
第四幕。比尔·克林顿的7岁弟弟。
Reporter Mary Wiltenburg is in the middle of this yearlong series that she's writing for The Christian Science Monitor about two boys, brothers who were born in a Tanzanian refugee camp and then resettled in Georgia two and a half years ago. Many of her stories are focused on the older brother, nine-year-old Bill Clinton Hadam. His dad is a big fan of the former president.
记者玛丽·威尔滕堡正在为《基督教科学箴言报》撰写关于两个男孩的年度系列报道，他们是出生在坦桑尼亚难民营、两年前重新安置在佐治亚州的兄弟。她的许多故事都集中在哥哥，九岁的比尔·克林顿·哈达姆身上。他爸爸是这位前总统的忠实粉丝。
After a tough first year in the United States, Bill seems to have settled in now, but his little brother Igey is still struggling to understand his own origin story to get his seven-year-old brain around who he is and where he came from. At this point, Mary has spent so much time with these two boys that she is more than a reporter. She's like a member of the family. Here's Mary.
在美国度过了艰难的第一年之后，比尔似乎现在已经安定下来了，但他的弟弟伊吉仍在努力理解自己的起源故事，试图让七岁的脑袋理解他是谁以及他来自哪里。此时，玛丽与这两个男孩在一起的时间如此之长，以至于她不仅仅是一名记者。她就像家庭的一员。这是玛丽。
Igey calls me on the phone almost every day. Sometimes he leaves messages.
伊吉几乎每天都给我打电话。有时他会留言。
First unheard message.
第一条未听留言。
Hello, Mary. This is me, Igey, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE] says Bill is going to summer school and I'm not going to summer school. OK, this is me, Igey. OK, bye!
你好，玛丽。是我，伊吉，[听不清]说比尔要去上暑期学校，我不去上暑期学校。好的，是我，伊吉。好的，拜！
In between the messages, we have long chats. I tape most of our conversations because I'm writing these articles about him and his family. And the conversations always seem to start with one of two questions: When can I come to your house? Or when are you coming to my house?
在留言之间，我们会进行长时间的聊天。我录下了我们大部分的谈话，因为我正在写关于他和家人的文章。对话似乎总是以两个问题之一开头：我什么时候能去你家？或者你什么时候来我家？
Hello.
你好。
Mary? You almost here?
玛丽？你快到了吗？
Oh, I'm going to be there soon. I'm in the car right now, driving to you, and there's a little bit of traffic.
哦，我很快就会到那儿了。我正在车里，正开车过去，有一点交通堵塞。
You're driving now?
你现在在开车？
I'm driving right now.
我现在在开车。
You're coming to take us, though, right?
不过，你是来接我们的，对吧？
I am, yes.
是的。
So you know I'm crazy about this kid. He's sweet, nosy, funny. He's been to my house a bunch since I started doing these stories. But the first time he came over, six months ago, he announced to me and my husband and his brother Bill Clinton that from now on, the first grader, formerly known as Igey, would be going by his middle name: John.
所以你知道我多喜欢这个孩子。他可爱、爱管闲事、有趣。自从我开始写这些故事以来，他去过我家很多次。但他第一次过来时，也就是六个月前，他向我和我丈夫以及他的哥哥比尔·克林顿宣布，从现在起，这位以前叫伊吉的一年级学生，将改用他的中间名：约翰。
I'd already known something was up, because that afternoon my husband took Igey to the park. Igey was up on the jungle gym when a girl about the same age called over from the swing set and asked his name, and he got all weird and wouldn't answer her. She thought he hadn't heard her, so she hopped off the swing, came over to the jungle gym, and asked him again, What's your name? Igey got this kind of cornered look and said, I don't know my name. But by later that night, he seemed to have made a decision. He was now John.
我早就知道出事了，因为那天下午我丈夫带伊吉去公园。伊吉正在丛林健身架上时，一个差不多大年纪的女孩从秋千架那边喊过来问他的名字，他变得很奇怪，不回答她。她以为他没听见，所以她跳下秋千，走到健身架旁，又问了他一遍，你叫什么名字？伊吉露出了那种被困住的表情说，我不知道我的名字。但当天晚些时候，他似乎做出了决定。他现在是约翰了。
In our living room, he struggled to type his new name into a video game. J- O- wait, was it J? Or G? Then Bill offered to help. Igey said, I know how to spell my own name.
在我们的客厅里，他努力把他的新名字输入到一个视频游戏里。J-O-等等，是J吗？还是G？然后比尔主动提出帮忙。伊吉说，我知道怎么拼写我自己的名字。
Igey picked up English first and best of anyone in his family. But his teachers say Igey's more confused about where he's from and who he is than other seven-year-olds they've seen. And the charter school Igey and Bill attend is about half refugees, so you think they'd see a lot of this. Teachers say no. Little kids usually realize pretty fast that most people who ask where are you from, they don't want the whole story. And it doesn't really matter if you say you're from Burma, where your parents were from, or Thailand, where you lived in a camp. In first grade, you just pick one and get on with your day.
伊吉是家里第一个也最好地掌握英语的人。但他的老师说，比起他们见过的其他七岁孩子，伊吉对自己的来源和身份更加困惑。伊吉和比尔就读的特许学校里大约有一半是难民，所以你会认为他们会见识很多这样的情况。老师们说没有。小孩子通常很快意识到大多数问你从哪里来的人，他们并不想要整个故事。不管你说你来自你父母出身的缅甸，还是你生活过的泰国，都没关系。在一年级，你只要选一个然后继续你的一天就行了。
But for Igey, where are you from has never felt that simple. All winter he seemed to be revising his story. First he denied the camp he'd lived in his whole life, hated the word "refugee." Then he started saying he wasn't from Congo, his nationality, or Tanzania, where he was born, or Africa at all. He'd say, I'm from here, or, America.
但对伊吉来说，你从哪里来从来没觉得那么简单。整个冬天他似乎都在修改他的故事。首先他否认了他一生居住的难民营，讨厌“难民”这个词。然后他开始说他不是来自刚果，他的国籍，也不是来自坦桑尼亚，他出生的地方，或者根本不是来自非洲。他会说，我来自这里，或者，美国。
Watching TV, he'd point to rich, white kids and say, That's me. At home, he threw tantrums. At school, he sometimes seemed almost catatonic. He wouldn't answer questions, wouldn't meet people's eyes. His parents, his teachers, everyone felt helpless. They didn't know what set him off or how to reach him. And he seemed to regress. If you were sitting on the couch, he'd snuggle up or take my hand. The slightest things made him cry. He seemed lost.
看电视时，他会指着富有的白人孩子说，那是我。在家里，他大发脾气。在学校，他有时看起来几乎进入了木僵状态。他不回答问题，不与人对视。他的父母，他的老师，每个人都感到无助。他们不知道是什么触动了他或者如何触达他。而且他似乎退步了。如果你坐在沙发上，他会偎依过来或者拉着我的手。最微小的事情都会让他哭泣。他看起来迷失了。
One night on the phone, I reminded him where he was born: in Tanzania. I'm from Tanzania?, he said.
有一天晚上在电话里，我提醒他出生在哪里：在坦桑尼亚。我来自坦桑尼亚？他说。
I'm from Tanzania?
我来自坦桑尼亚？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I am?
我是吗？
Well, that's where you were born.
嗯，那是你出生的地方。
Yeah, but where am I from?
是的，但我来自哪里？
Well, you were born in Tanzania. And your dad came from Congo.
嗯，你出生在坦桑尼亚。你爸爸来自刚果。
He did?
他来自那里吗？
And your mom came from Rwanda. So your family has a lot of places where you're from.
而你妈妈来自卢旺达。所以你的家人有很多你来自的地方。
'kay. Bye.
好。拜。
Bye!
拜！
Igey's parents didn't mind calling him John. They were just kind of puzzled. The idea that you could hate your name seemed like one more baffling thing about America. They just had no idea what Igey was going through, and it made Igey feel more distant from them.
伊吉的父母并不介意叫他约翰。他们只是有点困惑。你可以讨厌你的名字这个想法看起来像是关于美国又一件令人困惑的事情。他们根本不知道伊吉在经历什么，这让伊吉觉得离他们更远了。
A while back, I was riding with Igey and his parents in their car when he said to me, I don't want to live with my mom. I thought it was a setup for one of his jokes, so I said, You don't want to live with your mom? Why? He said, I want to live with you. I said, No, you don't want to live with me. But then Igey got all serious and said, But what if I forget my language? I said, What do you mean? And he said, If I forget my language, I can't live with them, because they won't understand me.
前不久，我正和伊吉以及他的父母在车里，他对我说，我不想和我妈妈住在一起。我以为这只是他开玩笑的前奏，所以我说，你不想和你妈妈住在一起？为什么？他说，我想和你住在一起。我说，不，你不想和我住在一起。但接着伊吉变得很严肃说，但如果我忘了我的语言怎么办？我说，你什么意思？他说，如果我忘了我的语言，我就不能和他们住在一起，因为他们听不懂我。
Later on the phone, we talked about what it's like for him talking with his mom.
后来在电话里，我们谈论了他和他妈妈谈话是什么感觉。
When you speak English, does she understand you?
当你讲英语时，她听得懂吗？
No.
听不懂。
So maybe you're learning faster, huh?
所以也许你学得比较快，是吧？
I just forget it right now.
我刚才忘了它。
Swahili?
斯瓦希里语？
Yes.
是的。
Like what do you forget?
比如你忘了什么？
Everything.
什么都忘了。
And then at some point this spring, Igey just went back to being Igey. A lot of things happened for him at once. His green card arrived. His reading took off. It took me a while to notice that John had vanished.
然后在今年春天的某个时候，伊吉又变回了伊吉。一连串的事情同时发生在他身上。他的绿卡到了。他的阅读突飞猛进。我花了一段时间才注意到约翰已经消失了。
His teachers don't remember either exactly when he stopped correcting them. But by the last month of school, he was taking his turn in the semicircle with everyone else. No drama, just my name is Igey and I'm from Congo. And suddenly, he was volunteering details about his life in the camp: games he played, his mud brick house. Igey seemed to be making peace with his past and his name, and he moved on to other burning seven-year-old questions.
他的老师也不记得他什么时候停止纠正他们了。但到了学期的最后一个月，他和其他人一起轮流坐在半圆圈里。没有戏剧性，只是我的名字是伊吉，我来自刚果。突然，他自愿分享关于他在营地生活的细节：他玩的游戏，他的泥砖房。伊吉似乎正在与他的过去和名字和解，他转向了其他燃烧的七岁孩子的疑问。
What's bingo nights mean?
宾果之夜是什么意思？
You know how you play bingo at school?
你知道你在学校怎么玩宾果吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
It's like a night when a bunch of adults get together, maybe kids, too, and they play a game that's like that, only with numbers instead of words.
那就像是一个晚上，一群成年人聚在一起，也许还有孩子，他们玩一个像那样的游戏，只是用数字而不是单词。
OK, I'm ready for you.
好的，我准备好你了。
Oh, OK. I'll see you soon.
哦，好的。我很快会见到你。
'kay, bye.
好的，拜。
Bye.
拜。
And just when it seemed like Igey had finally accepted his own name, the other shoe dropped. The last week of school, Igey asked me, um, what does gay mean? I told him gay can mean happy, or it can mean when a man loves another man.
而就在伊吉似乎终于接受了自己的名字时，另一只鞋掉了下来。学期的最后一周，伊吉问我，嗯，同性恋（gay）是什么意思？我告诉他gay可以指快乐，也可以指当一个男人爱另一个男人时。
Igey started sobbing. We were in his kitchen, and he just collapsed against the fridge. Finally, he choked out what was wrong, and it turned out that some second graders had been taunting him: Igey, you're gay. And he told them, that's not a word. It's just one more strike against that name. But for now, John hasn't reappeared. Igey's sticking with Igey.
伊吉开始啜泣。我们在他的厨房里，他只是崩溃地靠在冰箱上。最后，他哽咽着说出有什么问题，结果是一群二年级学生一直在嘲笑他：伊吉，你是同性恋。他告诉他们，那不是一个词。这对那个名字来说只是又一次打击。但目前为止，约翰没有重新出现。伊吉坚持用伊吉这个名字。
The other day, when we were riding in the car, I said some offhand thing about needing to call my mom. Igey said, You have a mom? I said, Yeah, of course. He could not believe it. How had he not known about this before? This year, it's been hard enough for Igey to put together his own story. The idea that I-- wait, everybody comes from somewhere? It kinda blew his mind.
那天，当我们坐在车里时，我随口说了句需要给我妈打个电话。伊吉说，你有妈妈？我说，是的，当然。他简直不敢相信。他怎么以前不知道这件事呢？今年，伊吉拼凑自己的故事已经够难了。每个人都来自某个地方的想法？这让他大开眼界。
Mary Wiltenburg of The Christian Science Monitor . She's working on a book about Igey, Bill Clinton and their family.
玛丽·威尔滕堡，来自《基督教科学箴言报》。她正在写一本关于伊吉、比尔·克林顿和他们家庭的书。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Our production help Randy Dixon. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Thanks today to Bob Folkenflik, Matt Holtzman and Hank Rosenfeld. Pino Audia's research paper about garages and entrepreneurs that I talked about at the beginning of the show was done with Christopher Rider. Dan Heath, who we also talked to at the top of the show is the co-author of the book Made to Stick: Why Some Ideas Survive and Others Die. Barry Siegel's book from Act Two of our show is just out in paperback. Claim of Privilege is what it's called.
我们的节目今天由莉萨·波拉克和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、肖恩·科尔、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·科尼格、阿莉萨·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的制作协助是兰迪·迪克森。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀。今天感谢鲍勃·福尔肯弗里克、马特·霍尔茨曼和汉克·罗森菲尔德。我在节目开头谈到的关于车库和创业者的皮诺·奥迪亚的研究论文是与克里斯托弗·莱德共同完成的。我们在节目开头也采访过的丹·希思是《粘住：为什么有些点子能流传而有些会死亡》一书的合著者。我们节目第二幕中巴里·西格尔的书刚刚出了平装本。《特权主张》是它的名字。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International WBEZ. Management oversight for a program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who hears himself quoted in these credits every single week and says, "I never said that. I would never say that."
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司WBEZ分发。我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生对节目的管理监督，他每周都在这些制作名单中听到自己被引述，并说：“我从没那样说。我绝不会那样说。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI: Public Radio International.
PRI：公共广播国际公司。